yeah i think there's one korean horror
that you might really like i think you
just said there's one korean [ __ ] i was
like
one korean horror movie yeah no there's
one asia goes hard on horror like that
yeah they don't want to just entertain
you they wanted to psychologically scar
you yeah such respect for asian horror
films asian horror films i won't watch
them
they take it one step too far like for
instance if i was a director right a
korean director if i was an american
director like i think parasite was like
a rom-com over there for them okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah it did have a very funny
comedic vibe to it but i'm telling you
the whaling this one
i think you'd like this this one is so
good why you don't like [ __ ] uh asian
architecture
um i do
that's what it's about i do but only if
there's asians in there yeah yeah you
gotta watch this i don't wanna meet a
white guy coming out that door so you
know what
we love sushi we just figured we'd go
with that that theme yeah so you don't
watch anything right now at all
nothing that's so [ __ ] liberating
right to just be like yeah i don't care
dude it's you got you have to see it
it's so good you know it was everybody's
going it's so good
like that yeah all right oh yeah [ __ ]
it's a little bit of a turn off you have
to see it and it's kind of like well or
you could like save me
15 hours of my [ __ ] life and just
tell me what happens all right i'll tell
you what happens what happens in squid
game
[Laughter]
you want me to tell you yeah all right
so
if i can remember
there's a guy
all right he's gonna do this i'm gonna
do it i don't give a [ __ ]
by the way if squid games pitch this
this pitch this to the network they
wouldn't even got picked up
and
you're not you're a [ __ ] executive i'm
pitching it all right so it's about a
korean guy all right it's in korea
that's why green light it we've been
racist we just need people of color
there you go oh just do it thank you
absolutely can i get a white people in
it no white people no no there's
actually there's is he toxic
yes yes green light
yeah killed in it does that make me less
racist
yes there's a guy who's down on his luck
korean dude he gambles on the side right
he's stealing stamford and son meets
korea no i'm not done let me love it
excuse me executive can i pitch may i
finish the pitch all right so anyway so
he's desperate for money he's also in he
owes money to loan sharks do i have
everything right so far right and so
loan sharks find him
he's after like a gambling thing we was
at a i'm not pitching this well and so
and they make him sign something he
doesn't know he's signing basically what
he's signing is to be involved in a game
called squid game
and and it's for people that um are in
debt they make money
what people like more of a salmon role
it has nothing to do with [ __ ]
seafood i'm sorry
okay it has nothing to do with seafood
executives don't forget to wake up check
to asian awareness
so sorry it's okay
may i finish yes i'm loving this right
so anyway um people who are in debt of
er in the show
sign up for this thing called the school
my wife and i just went to downtown
chinatown and we loved it okay that has
nothing to do
that has nothing to do with what i'm
saying just trying because it's crazy
and i know
you're very open and um
executive anyway let me finish um
but the what the squid games is is
basically
a competition
and um
like the but a series of games that
people play they're locked
into this on this island the hunger
games meets the fish market exactly yes
it's hunger games means
an okinawa fish market
that's what it is i mean i love it thank
you who do you see casting
that woman from crouching tiger
yeah does she float
she yes over there how does she float
over
wild walk oh yeah she won't walk right
heads
and there's um a lot of blood anyways so
thank you i think you should see it bill
and that's the last time i'm gonna ask
you to see it [ __ ] it
did i do a good job dude is it
interesting i'm i'm guessing he wins at
least the first [ __ ] season or else
the show's over
yeah
that's true there we go yeah yeah but
what are you really ruining
the suspense of him getting where i know
he's gonna be no because there's a lot
of twists and turns if i told you what
those are right now you'd be like some
people call it suspense other people
call it twists and turns
yeah some yeah there's a lot of switches
a lot of love with that laugh
that was literally like i just poked
your belly i know
what the [ __ ] bro don't you remember
like uh the michelin man oh no no no no
no no no no no no
yeah
yeah yeah he used to do that
uh anyway i won't watch matrix or
ghostbusters so just it's done i'm done
with that are you [ __ ] tired of that
[ __ ]
i think it's amazing how much [ __ ]